Speaker 1: Also insane over the last 24
hours. There is a new Rolling Stone report.
Trump asking advisers for Battle plans to
attack Mexico if reelected. This is truly
horrifying. He probably watched an episode of
Narcos Mexico and was like, I should get some
plans to invade. The article reads Trump and his
magnified Republican Party are pushing plans for
military action against drug cartels in Mexico,
with or without the Mexican government's consent.
Trump is asking for a plan to wage war in Mexico,
and the Republican Party is eager to give it to
him. Trump has been asking policy advisers for
military options to take on Mexican drug cartels,
including doing strikes not sanctioned by
Mexico's government, according to two sources
familiar with the situation. Attacking Mexico, or
whatever you'd like to call it, is something that
President Trump has said he wants battle plans
drawn for, says a source. He's complained about
missed opportunities of his first term, and
there are a lot of people around him who want
fewer missed opportunities in his second term.
Listen to this. Trump lieutenants. Imagine having
lieutenants. Trump lieutenants have briefed him on
several options that include unilateral military
strikes and troop deployments on a sovereign
U.S. partner and neighbor. Can you imagine
the United States unilaterally deploying troops in
Mexico? This is exact you know, when we talk about
Trump wanting to nuke a hurricane. Trump not
understanding why considering using nukes on
Europe is insane. This is the sort of stuff we're
talking about. This is the really dangerous stuff.
One such proposal that Trump has been briefed
on is a white paper from the Center for Renewing
America, which is increasingly influential, and
it's staffed by Trump wonks and MAGA loyalists.
And it's called It's Time to Wage War on
Transnational drug Cartels. This is all so
insane, so insane. What they should do
is come to Trump, you know, these big,
strong guys, they should go to Trump
with tears in their eyes and say, Sir,
the wall you built, it's so powerful that we can
no longer invade Mexico. The wall is too tall for
us to invade and attack Mexico. We can't do it.
This is an example of the dangerous nature of
another Trump presidency because he will be even
more unhinged. The counterpoint is. Trump's not
really going to do this, but Ron DeSantis, if he
were the president, might actually do some really
dangerous stuff. I can see it both ways. I really
can. But these are horrifyingly dangerous ideas.